when you're fundraising i typically
encourage founders
to imagine that you have about three
months
that fundraising's gonna take three
months that there are two fundraising
windows
you could do it after january second to
july fourth
or you could do it from september 10th
through to thanksgiving
those are really your only two windows
now it's a little bit different today
with predominantly zoom conversations
but
the important piece here is that folks
disappear in august tend to disappear in
august
if you don't have tons of folks who are
willing to sort of engage in the process
or available to engage in the process
then it reduces your likelihood of a
successful outcome fundraising is binary
either happens or it doesn't and so the
best way to sort of create
a structure and process to this is to
run one if your last pitch is your best
pitch
uh what we'll typically do or what i'll
typically do is
for 30 days i will meet with 20 to 30
founders these are founders who are
one stage ahead of us um or two stages
ahead of
us who have raised venture capital i'll
sit down with them i'll have a
preliminary deck like i just showed you
it'll be a really bad version of it but
just have anything
and i will pitch density to them and
tell them i'm about to open a
fundraising process but i haven't yet
and i'd really like feedback on what
works and what doesn't and these are
trusted folks like they don't have a
skin in the game they just want to be
helpful you do as many of them as you
possibly can
like stack them by the end of that
process two things will have happened
one well three things will have happened
your deck will have gotten materially
better
like way better number two you will have
found founders who want to invest in you
certainly at the earlier stages and if
they don't invest in you they
will likely intro introduce you to their
gps so the people that
invested in them if they're excited
number three
you will be substantially tighter on
your pitch
and those introductions that founders
make to you sort of in the process
you want to schedule for month two so
anybody who asks if you want to
if you want to talk about fundraising if
you're actively fundraising right now
or if you've had outreach from investors
don't take the meeting strongly
encourage you not to take the meeting
you're you're probably not
i am bad at fundraising right now
because i haven't been practicing for
the last 30 days
so use that first month to sort of
prepare second month you schedule
meetings and the way that you you want
to think about scheduling meetings is um
i strongly encourage a screening week
where you do
30-minute meetings and those 30-minute
meetings are with investors
anyone who's interested anyone that you
might have gotten intro to
previously from the founders that you
prepared with the screening meeting
should be about 30 minutes long
half of it you should grill them with
questions what's the size of your fund
where are you in your fund cycle are you
raising a new fund soon how many
investments have you made how many
boards do you sit on
are you a gp how do you make decisions
is there an investment committee do you
have competing investments in
a similar space what's average check
size the reason you want to ask these
questions is it's going to give you
substantially more information
as to what and how they invest and
more importantly if you ask these
questions and you show interest in that
process like you know
do their lps have material input in what
they invest in do they have a particular
thesis or mandate
if you ask those types of questions or
even half of the ones i just mentioned
it will demonstrate a fluency in raising
venture capital or in
what they deal with on their side that
demonstrates sort of a serious
the seriousness that you're taking this
you're not just talking about you you're
asking about them
you're looking for a really great
partner i am not hard-lined about only
talking to gps or managing directors or
you know not talking to associates i
would say associates are can become your
best friends
like truly the people that help make
deals happen
however gps general partners and
managing directors
are the folks that can push a deal
through you you need and want a gp
sponsor
and so i strongly encourage in in the
event that you can
to ask that a specific general partner
join your screening meeting
and as many as many associates and
principals as want to join
first 15 minutes and i mean hard 15
minutes are asking them questions and
taking notes
the next 15 minutes and only 15 minutes
you open it up for questions
say what would you like to know about
density i'm happy to answer anything
that you want to know
and the really great investors will say
actually
i'm really curious about x i did some
research and i'm really
sort of hung up on or i want to know
about
the average investors will say tell me
where you were founded you know tell me
about the beginnings you know
the difference between those two things
tends to be preparation and the ones
that are really prepared
those are the ones that are more likely
to lean in later on the ones that are
just like
hey just tell me about how you were
founded take meetings like that
all the time and so your job is to sort
of only spend 15 minutes answering
questions and the reason you only want
to spend 15 minutes answering questions
and they can ask anything like truly
give them the opportunity to ask
anything
do not share your deck with them just
talk or answer questions about density
or whatever the
company is the reason you want to do
that is because you you can't i don't
know if you bleep this out you probably
can't [ __ ] up 15 minutes
but you are much more likely to [ __ ] up
30 minutes or an hour
if they are your first conversations
with with investors 15 minutes is very
hard if you
are you know really in the game and
building a great business
the other thing that's useful is that it
allows you to keep the time short so
that you can focus on
understanding them and whether or not
you want to put them as a part of your
process
next week the following week i promise
i'll i'll wrap this process relatively
soon but
these are some of the mistakes i've made
in the past your next week or your next
two weeks
you're now in month two you've done your
screening meetings you've done do as
many of them as you want back to back
but keep them to 30 minutes and take
notes on everybody your second week
or your third week in that second month
you're gonna have your first
actual investor meetings which you have
scheduled the month
prior and the reason you want to do that
is investors are not busy a month from
now
they're busy next week and they're busy
in two weeks and they're busy in three
weeks but they're not busy
in four and six weeks and that's because
they're usually reserving time to sit
down with founders and like take
meetings so
schedule it a month out you will almost
always get on their calendar provided
you get a warm introduction
which by the way is really the only way
that you want to to generate
introductions as warm introductions from
founders that they've invested in those
are the best
possible intros the next best possible
intro is an introduction from
your investor um your previous investors
and the reason and i'm going to get back
to the weeks in a second but the reason
that's important is because
previous investors have something called
an irr or internal rate of return
that's how they mark up their
investments so
let's say i raise 100 million dollar
fund and that 100 million dollar fund i
invest in a whole bunch of companies and
it's it's sort of all gone
maybe i reserve some of it for follow on
investing but let's say i've been i've
allocated the vast majority of 100
million and i need to raise my next fund
well that hundred million dollars i
raised just two years ago
the goal is to return the fund it is
unlikely that i've seen material returns
in that two years
so you use what's called an irr which is
a markup for any of the investments that
i made in that period
on their post-money valuation for the
next
investor equity rounds not convertible
notes
and there's a important technical
distinction there by understanding what
they're trying to do and what's
important to them
you are much more likely to successfully
fundraise so let's get back to the weeks
your second week you have scheduled
meetings with all of these other folks
you really don't want to do more than
two a day you get a morning slot you got
an afternoon slot the reason for that is
and these are hour-long meetings
and you have uh asked or encouraged them
or they have asked you for a meeting
where you actually are going to go
through your pitch
now remember you've done 20 30 pitches
by this point
50 pitches by this point you are super
tight you love every slide that's in
your deck
you put in a lot of effort you're in
your second week you're doing one in the
morning and one in the afternoon the
reason you're doing it
no more than two you can make exceptions
to this if you have to
but no more than two is because you're
gonna forget what you told somebody
if you do three you're gonna forget you
already told the story your job is to
tell the same story over and over again
because it's a tight story and then the
small deviations that an investor asks
questions of
the the important part is that you you
really don't feel like you're repeating
yourself so
uh two a day is enough ideally you got
ten slots
monday through friday your first four
days
three to four days should be warm up you
should be
not putting your top most important
investor
or firm that you want to work with or
important gp or whoever it might be
in those first four days three or four
days you want to put
folks that are maybe lower down your
list you know folks you don't know or
folks that are really excited about you
but you haven't gotten familiar with or
maybe funds that you you think that you
might have a good
you might work with but you just you
haven't spent a lot of time with and put
your sort of
number one number two number five uh
later on
pick your best investor the one that is
your dream investor the one that you
know you want
because you did all this prep ahead of
time and you're listening to youtube and
you were
trying to understand who these folks are
on friday
friday afternoon and your morning is
again a warm up
friday afternoon should be the best
pitch you've ever done because your last
pitch is always your best pitch
and what that will do is it will allow
you to give an early look
to the one that you really want to work
with
but you will be prepared enough to show
it polished
what what's happened in that first week
and then then you move on to your
second week in your third week and those
second and third weeks you stack with
the folks that you actually you know
truly want to raise from
but you just stack them two a day and
you do them
back to back you you do not run your
business and fundraise
you fundraise or run your business
it is a full-time effort i think when i
was running fundraising last time i
i i think i lost something like 17
pounds
and it was because i didn't drink i went
to bed early i drank a lot of water
i was going to the gym it was like a
monk like life for for
you know a period of time we were in
market for nine days
meaning when we opened conversations to
term sheet sign term sheet
and we were very fortunate to work with
kleiner perkins uh who was
at the top of my list um and a
remarkable gp
named ilya fuschman who's partnered with
mamoon
who i think has been on on this this uh
the show
um and it was because we put in the work
ahead of time i think
another really important note is like
the reason you're doing all of this is
because you need them all to mature at
the same time
if you do sequential meetings they're
gonna mature
in sequence meaning you're gonna have a
bad meeting early
you're gonna fast forward a month and a
half you're still gonna be fundraising
you're gonna be meeting with a friend of
the person who passed on you a month and
a half ago
and they're going to say hey i'm looking
at this company you know anything about
oh yeah i've met with them i met with
them like
you know i don't know two months ago did
you invest no
no it's not it's too early for me or
they didn't they don't really have the
traction that they need or
and it wasn't because you weren't a
great company it was because your
narrative wasn't tight
i mean maybe it's because you weren't a
great company in which case i can't help
you but
if you've got a great company there's no
reason why you shouldn't be able to
raise capital certainly not in this
environment it doesn't need to be
and it doesn't need to be frothy to
raise
to raise capital some of the best
companies in the world raised in
economic downturns
so anyway the point is you need them all
to mature at the same time and you need
to be prepared
because if you're not prepared that
first person is literally going to tank
that meeting that you have they're going
to walk in a no
and it's because they've got a friend
who passed on you previously your job
when you get a meeting is to get the
next meeting
and you just keep getting the next
meeting until you have a term sheet and
once you have a term sheet your job is
to get
a second term sheet so that you have
some pricing leverage over over the the
deal
and then you know i would say the reason
that you budget uh three months
and you work in those seasons is so that
you can have time for clothes
so if it's 30 days for prep it's 30 days
for
meetings it's 30 days for diligence and
clothes approximately that is
best case scenario in my opinion you're
gonna read all sorts of
crazy tech crunch articles about uh oh
like the brex founders we put together
a we don't put any effort into our deck
because that would demonstrate that
we're too focused on fundraising and
we're not growing fast enough
i think the brex founders are awesome i
think that's a [ __ ] argument
for not putting in the effort and i'm
not brex we've not done what brex has
done
in terms of growth so i i have to i
defer you know i don't have the
credibility to say that
but if you put in the work uh and you
you do the prep you don't have to sweat
the test you are substantially more
likely to end up the partner that is
excellent in the long term